FACING A RECKONING.
>> Bret: THANKS.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, THE THIRD
STORY IN A ROW, THERE ARE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE HUNTER BIDEN
EMAIL STORY.
HERE’S A SENIOR POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL IN
WASHINGTON.
>> ONE SENIOR FEDERAL OFFICIAL
TELLS FOX NEWS THE FBI AND DOJ
CONCUR WITH DNI JOHN RATCLIFFE’S
ASSESSMENT THAT HUNTER BIDEN’S
LAPTOP AND EMAILS WERE NOT PART
OF A RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
SENIOR FEDERAL OFFICIALS SAYS
THE FBI IS IN POSSESSION OF THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP IN QUESTION,
THAT BREAKING MOMENTS AGO.
ALSO LATE TODAY A NEW PHOTO HAS
EMERGED IN "THE NEW YORK POST"
SHOWING FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN’S SON HUNTER AND
PURPORTED CAUSE OFFICIALS, WE
ARE CHECKING WITH OUR SOURCES AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT IT AND IN
PROPER CONTEXT AS WITH ALL NEW
REVELATIONS IN THIS HUNDRED
BIDENS STORY.
>> BIG TECH ABOUT TO BE UNDER
THE SPOTLIGHT, NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE WITH THE SENATE
JUDICIARY WHICH IS THREATENING
SUBPOENAS FOR THE CEOs OF
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER ON
THURSDAY.
>> NO MORE FOOT DRAGGING,
PROACTIVE ACTION HERE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCENTRATION, ADDRESSED THE
POWER COME ADDRESS THE
CENSORSHIP.
>> SOME REPUBLICANS CHARGING
CENSORSHIP, EVEN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AS THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS BLOCK A DISTRIBUTION
OF THE INITIAL HUNTER BIDEN
EMAIL STORY.
>> LOOK AT ALL THE CORRUPTION
AND HIS FAMILY COMMITS
TREMENDOUS CORRUPTION -- THAT
LAPTOP, NOBODY HAS EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ACCUSING
JOE BIDEN OF STAYING AWAY FROM
REPORTERS TO AVOID ANSWERING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS SON HUNTER’S
PURPORTED LAPTOP AND EMAILS, THE
PRESIDENT ALSO DUMPED ON THIS
MAY 2017 EMAIL WITH CHINESE
ENERGY EXECUTIVES VERIFIED BY A
SOURCE ON THE EMAIL CHAIN WHICH
DISCUSSES PAYMENT FOR SIX PEOPLE
PEOPLE.
IT INCLUDES A REFERENCE TO 10%
OF THE EQUITY IN THE DEAL BEING
HELD FOR THE BIG GUY, WHICH THE
SOURCES SAY IS JOE BIDEN.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT GOT A KICK
BACK AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT AND
THEY’VE KNOWN IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> FOX NEWS HAS OBTAINED IMAGES
INCLUDING WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
RECEIPT FROM THE WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE, COMPUTER REPAIR SHOP
SIGNED BY HUNTER BIDEN, IT ALSO
LISTED AN EMAIL AND CELL PHONE
NUMBER AND ALSO INFORMATION, IT
SHOWS THE BUREAU TOOK POSSESSION
OF AN ALLEGED HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP AND EXTERNAL HARD DRIVE
LAST SEPTEMBER, SENATE HOMELAND
SECURITY CHAIRMAN RON JOHNSON
WANTS ANSWERS ABOUT THE FBI’S
ACTIONS SINCE THEN.
TO SPEAK OF THE FBI -- IF THIS
SHOP OVER HIS FRAUDULENTLY
PEDDLING INFORMATION TO
CONGRESS, THAT’S A CRIME.
THE FBI OUGHT TO BRIEF US ON
THAT AS WELL.
>> INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST
GLENN GREENWALD NOTES THE BIDENS
CAMPAIGN SILENCE ON THE
AUTHENTICITY OF WHAT’S BEEN
REPORTED TO.
>> IN THE BIDEN CAMP, NOT ANYONE
IN THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS
INSINUATED LET ALONE STATED THAT
THE EMAILS ARE ANYTHING OTHER
THAN AUTHENTIC.
>> THE FBI HAS MADE EVERY EFFORT
TO STAY OUT OF THE 2020 ELECTION
AFTER IT WAS FRONT AND CENTER
WITH 2016, BUT TONIGHT SOME
BREAKING NEWS, WE ARE TOLD BY A
SENIOR FEDERAL OFFICIAL THAT THE
FBI IS IN POSSESSION OF A LAPTOP
AND THE FBI AND DOJ CONCUR WITH
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE THAT THIS IS NOT
PART OF A RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION